ma chérie qu'est ce qui s'est passé
parce que voilà c'est au programme
s'arrête c'est une émission culte voilà
les jeux les moins jeunes les plus âgés
les bois âgées voient tous regardé cette
émission moi le matin je vous rappelle
moi j'ai vécu des années je vous dis au
chômage et c'est vrai que tous les
matins je regardais sophie elle
m'accompagne
je te jure tu me poses et qui fait et
voilà ce qui fait regarder avec d'avenir
avec toute la bande et sophie qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en fait ils tondent et
ont appelé tu t'en douter ou pas du tout
il y avait quand même des bruits qui
courait depuis un certain temps l'an
dernier l'arrêt de catherine ceylac ça
nous est occupée fait un coup ces dix là
les émissions du matin sont menacés et
il ya des économies à faire dans cette
maison c'est la raison qu'on a invoqué
est manifestement il faut inverser
d'investir de l'argent sur les prêts ou
les secondes parties de soirée
maintenant 50 le lait donc économiser
sur les émissions du matin secret du
coin par un clou j'ai essayé de défendre
émission j'ai essayé d'avancer les
arguments de l'audience
les arguments de l'équipe parce que
c'est ça aussi qui m'attriste le plus
c'est que fut déclaré notre antenne de
salariés dont plus de la moitié dont on
ne sait pas quand même ce qu'il va
advenir d'eux donc voilà c'est triste et
puis voilà on aimait travailler ensemble
on aimait faire cette émission
moi je dors faire affaire conclue je
m'éclate à faire cette émission mais
intellectuellement c'était quand même
chouette tueur de traiter de tous les
sujets d'avoir des invités de les
choisir de produire cette émission donc
voilà c'est si mon souhait de retrouver
une aventure pas forcément comme ça mais
autre chose qui complète je prends on
vend pas on va en parler après l'arrêt
de c'est au programme
franchement je vous dis moi j'ai pas
compris que c'est vrai je vous le redis
l'émission cartonné sophistes et son
titre et du mythe là on en a parlé un
peu voilà très aimée parce que j'aime
j'aime les gens qui travaillent avec moi
depuis tant d'années et et voilà on a
des rapports familiaux je dirais donc ça
me touche qu'ils aient pris la peine de
faire ça que tu te dire moment je vais
quitter france télévisions
non je ne suis pas en suisse ont quitté
france qu'ils ont je crois même pas
maltraité sur cette chaîne depuis des
années et puis c'est vrai que je vis une
aventure formidable avec affaire conclue
que j'aime aussi beaucoup par ailleurs
j'aime aussi cette équipe et c'est
tellement rare à la télé un succès aussi
fulgurant aussi aussi énorme que 100 du
moi c'est non
donc voilà je suis contente d'être à la
tête de cette aventure et puis je fais
confiance à la direction j'espère que
ils vont utiliser toutes les capacités
que j'ai l'expérience que j'ai au
service d'autres choses que ce que tu as
envie de faire maintenant parce que mine
de rien je sais que tu as dû leur dire
ça ferait deux envie d'oublier un projet
de documentaire incarné sur un sujet qui
m'est cher donc un sujet autour des
femmes dont je parle avec la direction
donc à ce premier projet est le deuxième
projet c'est que je me dis qu'il ya pas
de femme très peu de femmes sur le
service public dans les divertissements
je sais que la chaîne est en train de
réfléchir à renouveler ses cases du
s'amusant soir ou dit vendredi soir sur
france 3 parce que le chantier est
ouvert et je me dis qu'aujourd'hui avec
aulas la petite expérience que j'ai
envie d'aller plus dans le
divertissement mais elle est très bonne
dans le divertissement du divertissement
a contenu où il ya des idées des
interviews affaires de l'émotion des
surprises des artistes moi je côtoie des
artistes depuis depuis 21 ans avec 7 au
programme et j'aime les attendait
j'aime bien les émissions avec qui ont
du sens et du contenu donc le
divertissement peut en être si on peut
faire on peut travailler on va voir et
ben je vais voir ce qu'on peut faire et
coûtent les sans droits - cv je rappelle
un gars tu veux que j'appelle la
directrice des divertissements de france
2 mais j'ai mal je l'appelle
je la connais très bien on l'appelle
tout de suite avec son drap reds et ben
tu vas la rencontre à venir
d'ailleurs quand même que je suis passé
90 enquêtes soit on n'a pas tout de
suite
la foule s'était alors c'est la
directrice talent et je l'appelle tout
de suite c'est quoi j'appelle tous les
états directrice des divertissements de
france 2 même dossier soit elle est en
transversal maintenance et toutes les
chaînes
alexandra qui s'appelle vous inquiétez
pas tout est à nous n'a pas l'appui que
tu veux alors comme une prime est ce que
tu dois faire ce qu'elle fout tout est
encore à donner les prime à nagui c'est
bon quoi ça va quoi il ya sophie davant
aussi elle existe à la ddt avant un set
au point la mère d'hathaway oui alors je
laisse à mes seins alexandra hanouna c8
je t'appelle chez un petit pont maire
d'hénin concernant la petite d'avant là
bah ouais parce que là on lui arrête
c'est au programme la meuf
elle a envie de faire d'autres trucs
auxquels me dit qu'elle serait chaude
sur du samedi soir bon si tu pouvais du
blog qu'il débloquait une douzaine de
preuves ça nous arrangerait est un
producteur
non alors à la pâte
avec aujourd'hui alors divertissement
égal
voilà moi tu sais je peux très bien
travaillé pour d'autres chaînes et des
autres voilà d'autres d'autres chaînes
donc tu es n'hésite pas à me rappeler au
public avant 21h15 parce qu'après il ya
les bodin's c'est tombera directement
sur la tv des bodin's d'accord que tu me
rappelles avant hanouna avec h comme
talons ont fait inquiète pas les douches
prime c'est réglé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]